c'est la dernière fois que tu fais ce
métier tu m'entends tu bosses comme un
crs city venise est devenue trop violent
parce qu'on a service sur le format de
ses cibles pour une affectation service
de protection des hautes personnalités
mais que jean jacques goldman
la seule chose que j'ai proposé tu
manges anthony les bonnets
il ya des caméras dans toutes les
chambres garder le mec de revenge avec
un appareil bien choisis et bien
[ __ ] qui aurait pu le dire plus tôt
y'a pas de mal être cocus un ski c'est
de bouffer tu crois qu'il ya un délire
possibles dont gerry et moi mais je sens
là pour moi oh [ __ ] d'accord ok cash
pistou moi j'adore contourne salangi
autour des bruits effrayants
tu as pris mon kit incluant des
accessits emmerich
j'ai eu l'image oui bah vous me la mets
très attendu gedimat